[Música]
la OPEP tomó una decisión que tiene
repercusiones internacionales el
organismo anunció que reducirá su
producción de petróleo en dos millones
de barriles por día se trata del mayor
recorte desde el inicio de la emergencia
sanitaria por la pandemia del Coby 19 un
recorte que equivale al 2% de la demanda
mundial la medida por supuesto amenaza
con disparar los precios a nivel
internacional mientras que varios países
entre ellos Estados Unidos criticaron la
decisión incluso acusaron a la OPEP de
alinearse en favor de Rusia veamos
el mayor recorte de la oferta petrolera
desde mayo 2020 en su primera reunión
cara a cara desde la pandemia de Kobe 19
la Organización de Países exportadores
de petróleo y sus aliados anunciaron que
van a reducir su bombeo de petróleo
mundial en dos millones de barriles
diarios a partir de noviembre un 2% de
la demanda global según la organización
la decisión Busca contener la caída de
los precios del petróleo y brindar
seguridad al mercado energético no
estamos poniendo en peligro los mercados
energéticos estamos brindando seguridad
y estabilidad a los mercados energéticos
los representantes de la organización
fueron cuestionados y algunos señalan
que la decisión sería una especie de
cooperación con Rusia una acusación que
rechazaron
Muéstrame Dónde está el acto de
beligerancia
el anuncio de este recorte ha tenido
consecuencias inmediatas impulsando el
alza de los precios del barril de
petróleo el brent alcanzó un máximo de
93,96 dólares nivel que no conseguía
desde el 15 de septiembre por su parte
Estados Unidos criticó la decisión
catalogando la de cortoplacista y
partidista
mire está claro que la OPEP más se
alinea con Rusia con el anuncio de hoy y
así al tomar esta decisión va a tener un
efecto en los países de ingresos
económicos bajos y medios
el anuncio se da en un contexto complejo
para la energía a nivel mundial la
invasión rusa de Ucrania disparó los
precios a máximos de casi una década
un panorama al que se le suma la
prohibición europea sobre la mayor parte
del petróleo Ruso y se enmarca como una
negativa ante los pedidos occidentales
de que la OPEP produzca más combustible
Pero entonces qué es la OPEP y porque
tiene resonancia a nivel internacional
pues la OPEP es la Organización de
Países productores y exportadores de
petróleo tiene su sede en la ciudad de
bien a la capital de Austria y fue
fundada en 1960 por países como Irán
Irak Kuwait Arabia Saudita y Venezuela
estas naciones lo que querían era hacer
frente a esa fuerte y sostenida caída de
los precios del petróleo que tuvieron
lugar durante la segunda mitad de la
década de los años 50 que afectaba
precisamente a esos países que son
exportadores que tenían hasta incluso
hasta el día de hoy sus economías
netamente basadas en la producción y en
la venta de petróleo a nivel
internacional en la actualidad está
compuesta por 13 países integrantes pero
también hay algunos países aliados o
cercanos Como por ejemplo México y
Noruega que se han alineado en algunas
de las políticas o medidas que adopta la
OPEP de América Latina solamente están
países como Venezuela que es un país
fundador como les decía y también hace
parte de este grupo Ecuador la misión
principal de este organismo es defender
los precios del petróleo Aunque algunos
países señalan a la OPEP de ser
verdaderamente un cartel de países que
buscan sus beneficios en cuanto a los
precios del petróleo Lo cierto es que
sus decisiones tienen impacto a nivel
internacional cómo está entonces el
contexto internacional para que la OPEP
haya tenido que tomar esta decisión En
qué se basa el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden para decir que la OPEP
se está alineando con Rusia para darle
un respiro ante las sanciones
internacionales que ha recibido por la
invasión a Ucrania Cuál es el efecto
inmediato de la reducción de la
producción a nivel internacional porque
eso se va reflejado en el bolsillo de
todo el mundo Quién gana y Quién pierde
lo vamos a analizar en esta edición del
debate y para conversar sobre este tema
saludamos a ramsa speech él es asesor de
asuntos energéticos y económicos se
conecta desde la ciudad de Villahermosa
en el Estado de Tabasco en México y
desde la ciudad de Buenos Aires en
Argentina se une esta conversación
Gerardo rabino Beach él es
vicepresidente del instituto argentino
de la energía general masconi ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden ser
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
los comentarios y las preguntas a través
de las redes sociales ya lo saben
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate guión bajo
f-24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa ya están
disponibles en podcast en diferentes
plataformas en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
pues comienzo dándole entonces la
bienvenida a Ramsés Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos hoy
Punto de partida que es la pregunta base
para conocer las posiciones de los
invitados ramses y está la OPEP dándole
ayuda o no a Rusia con este equilibrio
en los precios o lo que intenta hacer es
un equilibrio de precios o está
verdaderamente respondiendo ante una
necesidad del mercado
primero no está respondiendo a una
necesidad del mercado segundo está
haciendo el ajuste en función de que
Acuérdense que los países que están en
el open más no ha llegado a la
producción real que habían pactado hoy
la OPEP más tiene tres millones de
barriles diarios que no han llegado a lo
que pactaron en los acuerdos que tienen
desde el año 2020 y esto lo que conlleva
Es que de los tres millones que no ha
llegado en forma real hacen un recorte
dos millones reduciendo La Brecha de
solo un millón de poder llegar a la
parte real en papel pueden hacerle
cualquier recorte pero la parte real
hemos visto varios países de esta
organización junto con tus aliados que
no han llegado a la meta de producción
esto qué es lo que tiene que ver mucho
en cuanto a los precios del barril no
solo es el cambio de la reducción de la
producción si no estamos viendo también
escenarios que están
afectando mucho el proceso del barril
como es la incertidumbre y sobre todo la
falta de una certidumbre en la demanda
sobre todo parte mundial estamos viendo
un china que la refinería es tan
importante una mayor cantidad de crudo
de Rusia y de la India pero no estamos
viendo un incremento de la demanda en
ya vamos a hacer un panorama general de
lo que está sucediendo a nivel
internacional para entender porque se
están Tomando estas decisiones Gerardo
Quiero conocer su opinión Entonces esto
es o no una respuesta a una necesidad
del mercado Es simplemente una necesidad
para beneficiar los precios para este
grupo de países o
verdaderamente están tratando de darle
un salvavidas a Rusia en esta situación
que está viviendo a raíz de las
sanciones internacionales como lo vio
usted
Mire es una estrategia de OPEP que no es
una organización que responde totalmente
a los movimientos del mercado es
asombrosa la el Paralelo entre esta
crisis era del año 73 la literatura
económica nos dice que la OPEP siempre
ha fluctuado entre precio y cantidad y
esta vez está este optando por precio
Qué quiere decir esto reduce la
producción para
acceder a precios altos que esto ayuda a
Rusia indudablemente pero es una
estrategia propia de la organización que
ha sumado
claramente antes de la invasión a
Ucrania antes de la pandemia a Rusia
para responder a este realidades dentro
del mercado Internacional del petróleo
como la llegada de el petróleo de
esquisto de los Estados Unidos
que ha generado una competencia muy
fuerte y por lo tanto obliga a esta
organización adoptar estrategias que ya
digamos forman parte de su background
como ser la estrategia de reducir la
producción para mantener precios altos
Gerardo continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda la inversa y le preguntó que
expliquemos un poco cómo está el
panorama mundial la situación
internacional vemos que hay una crisis
general los países no lo están pasando
bien en términos económicos hay
inflación en la mayoría de los países y
hay mucha incertidumbre por los
diferentes aspectos que afectan a las
naciones dependiendo de la región donde
se encuentre pongámoslo en palabras
simples para el televidente común para
la persona a pie en América Latina que
quiere entender como esta decisión de la
OPEP va a empezar a repercutir en
precios y en decisiones o en aspectos
fundamentales de nuestro día a día Bueno
estamos en un momento del mundo en una
situación extraordinaria
digamos que
suma el conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania
Rusia el primer exportador mundial de
gas y
por ahí de petróleo este
y reconfigura todas las relaciones
geopolíticas internacionales frente a
esta situación es una situación en la
cual digamos los precios de la energía
se han disparado a niveles casi
récord históricos tenemos los
compromisos del cambio climático que
obligan a reducir el consumo de
combustibles fósiles para hacer frente
al calentamiento global estos dos
movimientos en realidad están jugando
hoy en una estrategia muy este
pronunciada
con distintos actores geopolíticos
Europa buscando reducir sus consumos de
hidrocarburos y dar más eficiencia y más
lugar a las energías renovables y
Estados Unidos buscando colocar su
yeloil y competir con los países
productores de la OPEP claro
Cuál es su opinión para complementar
este panorama general de la situación
usted ya mencionaba un poco esos
mercados a donde ha accedido Rusia que
son India y China pero china también
está empezando a presentar una leve
desaceleración en su economía
yo creo que lo más importante sobre este
precio de los barriles que estamos
viendo que vamos a tener en esta semana
de 10 dólares va a impactar
principalmente en la inflación y sobre
todo en la inflación subyacente donde
afecta principalmente los precios de los
combustibles hoy vamos a tener un gran
problema sobre los precios de los
combustibles Porque algunos países van a
tener que dar un subsidio como el caso
de México que lo dio en su momento dado
y varios países de América Latina
también están realizando lo mismo hemos
de entender que en Estados Unidos es
preocupante esto porque en Estados
Unidos no dan subsidios sino que está en
una forma libre del mercado aquí hay
algo importante en días hace dos días
Este tiene la presunción de poder
prohibir la exportación o limitar la
exportación de ciertos combustibles de
Estados Unidos hacia hemos de recordar
que Estados Unidos exporta más de 3.5
millones de barriles diarios de
combustibles donde un millón de barriles
exporta América Latina y a México está
exportando entre 800 y 850.000 barriles
aquí la gran importancia es la OPEP no
está viendo el cuestionamiento de la
inflación no Sabiendo si los países van
a tener que dar un subsidio están viendo
cómo tener una mayor de ingresos porque
hemos de recordar países como Arabia
Saudita México y otros depende mucho de
los ingresos de las exportaciones de
ramses en palabras simples eso Entonces
En qué se va a haber traducido en el
bolsillo del ciudadano común
directamente bueno esta ya lo menciona
El combustible va a ser más costoso
llenar los tanques de los combustibles
de los de los automóviles lo vemos en
Estados Unidos que ya hay muchas quejas
sobre todo en Estados Como por ejemplo
California donde el galón o el litro es
sumamente costoso y en otros países de
Suramérica por ejemplo Uruguay o en
Centroamérica Costa Rica que tienen
combustibles sumamente costosos y
homicidios Sí y eso que acabas de
comentar va a ser algo muy importante
porque ya vienen en ciertas zonas de
América Latina también no solo las
gasolinas combustibles sino algunos que
se utilizan para la calefacción Hemos
llegado estamos entrando en invierno y
no solo los combustibles el gas natural
también va a tener un gran valor porque
acuérdense sube el precio del barril y
depende también cuánto pueda subir el
gas natural en cuanto a los combustibles
el individuos de a pie va a tener una
gran duda sobre todo en cuanto a la
inflación Porque si va a tener una
inflación alta en el país donde esté las
costas las cosas van a costar más y al
mismo tiempo el precio de los
combustibles está incrementando y hoy
vamos a tener un gran fenómeno que en
todos los años se tiene es si el que
tiene un salario le van a aumentar el
salario y de acuerdo a la inflación en
enero en febrero aquí va a depender
Cuánto es el poder adquisitivo que pueda
tener el individuo en función del
incremento de los combustibles y en si
en su país no se controla la inflación
quiero ver si nos va a alcanzar el
dinero o en febrero el dinero suficiente
para poder subsanar cuando menos la
canasta básica o movernos o
transportarnos de un lado a otro o
simplemente el transporte público ver si
no hacen un ajuste en los países donde
se tenga que incrementar como precio
combustible Bueno pues ahí están las
advertencia y la sugerencia para todos a
tener cuidado con los gastos previendo
un poco lo que va a hacer el final de
año y lo que va a ser el inicio del 2023
que sin duda alguna entonces Esto va a
repercutir en la capacidad de compra que
vamos a tener con nuestros salarios en
la región en general por el panorama que
están explicando nuestros invitados
hablemos un poco
Ramsés y Gerardo de la posición que
tiene países como por ejemplo Arabia
Saudita hace unos meses vimos al
presidente biden reunirse con las
autoridades saudíes allí en riad para
hablar precisamente para que Arabia
Saudita pusiera en el mercado más
producción de petróleo para poder bajar
los precios generar un poco más de
oferta en ese mercado para que en
Estados Unidos bajaran los precios y
ahora pues la producción la reducen
como desconociendo todo que habían
pactado con Estados Unidos Cómo entiende
uno la necesidad de Arabia Saudita que
le toca jugar a las dos bandas o porque
este toma esta toma de decisiones
Gerardo
bueno
el contexto geopolítico es completamente
distinto
Arabia Saudita ve a los Estados Unidos
como un competidor Estados Unidos es el
primer productor mundial de petróleo y
busca mercados para exportarlo
fundamentalmente China y sudeste de Asia
en este contexto se explica la creación
de la Organización de Países
exportadores de petróleo Plus
incorporando a Rusia y a otros países
productores de petróleo y exportadores
en ese contexto la relación entre
Estados Unidos y agrarias Arabia Saudita
cambia diametralmente respecto de la que
tuvieron en el pasado y un este digamos
hecho que demuestra esto es que la flota
americana abandona el golfo Pérsico para
ubicarse en el mar del sur de la china
donde se van a jugar los nuevos digamos
este contextos
de competencia por la supremacía de la
economía en el mundo Entonces esto
Explica en cierta medida la actitud de
Arabia Saudita para quien ahora el
mercado de sudeste de Asia y de China
son
primordiales y su
actitud de competencia con los Estados
Unidos por esos mercados
pasó a preguntarle a Ramsés sobre la
estrategia que pueden seguir los países
latinoamericanos para hacer frente a
este aumento de los precios que
claramente va a tener lugar a raíz de
esta decisión vemos por ejemplo Estados
Unidos el presidente biden ya ordenó
liberar parte de las reservas
estratégicas de crudo que tiene a nivel
Federal este país usted mencionaba el
tema de los subsidios que más pueden
hacer los gobiernos latinoamericanos con
sus contextos y sus dificultades
económicas para sobrellevar esta este
aumento
Bueno lo más complicado sobre este
aumento Es que muchos de los países de
América Latina dependen sobre todo del
petróleo crudo que puedan tener en
producción y que puedan cubrir su
refinerías pero muchos de los países de
América Latina tienen ciertas
importaciones y mucho podemos decirle
Por ejemplo el mercado mexicano importa
casi el 70%. aquí en Estados Unidos lo
importante como acaba de comentar las
reservas que tiene Estados Unidos hoy en
día que tenían programadas sacar 180
millones de barriles en los próximos en
los últimos meses sólo han sacado 155
Pero hay un dato muy importante Estados
Unidos hace un año producía 11 millones
de barriles diarios y hoy han banco
incrementado un millón de barril Yo creo
que el presidente byden y en Estados
Unidos lo que van a hacer es incrementar
un millón de barriles diarios 13
millones de barriles diarios limitar
cierta cantidad de exportaciones sobre
todo de combustibles no todos y
incrementar el aumento de las
exportaciones hoy Estados Unidos está
portando ardor de tres punto cinco
millones de barriles diarios y con esto
lo que va a hacer Estados Unidos es
mantengo mi producción de 12 de barriles
diarios mando a la refinerías con
ciertos límite de importaciones y un
millón de barriles voy a tener
disponible para estar enviando a
nuestras reservas y mantenerlas creo que
Estados Unidos tiene una gran parte de
la batuta de cómo puede controlar el
precio del mercado la pregunta aquí es
cuánto le va a durar porque el problema
es que antes del verano en el 2023 tiene
que tener alta las reservas y tener
ciertos volumen de almacenamiento tanto
de gasolina y diesel para no tener y no
sufrir consecuencias en la época además
conducción en verano claro y teniendo en
cuenta que el invierno ya está a la
vuelta de la esquina para el hemisferio
norte Gerardo su opinión sobre sobre
este tema sobre qué pueden hacer los
países latinoamericanos entonces para
sobrellevar esta situación
para la Argentina esta situación es un
golpe muy fuerte la Argentina tiene
serios problemas económicos
y en el corto plazo como importador de
gas fundamentalmente
a pesar que estábamos hablando de
petróleo el gas Sigue los precios del
crudo
esta situación le va a producir una
grave situación económica
[Música]
acompañada de déficisificar e inflación
que que no puede bajar
hay otros países que tienen otros
incentivos por ejemplo Brasil hoy es uno
de los primeros productores de petróleo
de América Latina y lo ve también como
una oportunidad para exportar petróleo y
aumentar el ingreso de Divisas
Venezuela también está negociando Aunque
parezca mentira de Estados Unidos para
incrementar su producción y mitigar el
impacto de el corte de la producción de
los países del OPEP la situación en
América Latina es un poco variada Pero
para simplificar históricamente esto
ocurrido este tipo de situaciones
producen inflación
golpean el bolsillo de los consumidores
producen inseguridad de abastecimiento
energético e incertidumbre en el futuro
por lo tanto
frente a esta situación cada uno de los
países de América Latina tienen que
elaborar las políticas adecuadas para
disminuir su vulnerabilidad energética y
en cierta medida su dependencia de las
importaciones o de las exportaciones en
el caso de aquellos países para los
cuales el petróleo es la principal
fuente de ingresos
Gerardo estos escenarios a los que
estamos enfrentando en este momento
Vuelve a decirle a los gobiernos y a las
autoridades que es necesario poner la
velocidad a la transición energética y
al uso de energías limpias y dejar los
hidrocarburos o los derivados de
petróleo
buscarles algún sustituto a la región de
América Latina esta transición le ha
costado un poco de Europa nos lleva
mucha ventaja pero justamente la crisis
que están viviendo en este momento les
ha llevado a tener que revertir algunas
de las medidas y avances que ya tenían
vuelve a quedar esto sobre la mesa qué
tanto se puede avanzar o acelerar en esa
transición para evitar estos escenarios
en donde se afecta toda la economía en
general ramses su opinión Yo creo que la
transición energética y sobre todo
utilizar combustibles alternativos o
emigrar a la parte eléctrica creo que
está en un momento ahorita de standby no
vamos a ver una movilidad tan rápido y
lo importante aquí es ver de aquí al año
2025 de todos países que van a entrar en
cierto periodos de recesión en los
próximos dos trimestres observar cuál de
ellos van a salir en forma rápida Cuáles
van a controlar la inflación ya estamos
viendo países como Canadá Estados Unidos
y algunos de la comunidad europea que ya
están controlando la inflación no la
están bajando están controlando la
tendencia al alza la están bajando y
todos aquellos países que puedan
controlar la inflación reducir la
no tener salir de la recesión lo más
rápido posible que viene en los próximos
meses estos son los que van a poder
tener una transición acelerada los
países de América Latina tiene Tenemos
un gran problema porque muchos de ellos
dependen sobre todo de las exportaciones
que se venden del crudo porque gran
parte de los ingresos de las
administraciones dependen de esto en
México anteriormente era el 30% Hoy es
el 18% Venezuela sabemos que depende
mucho de las exportaciones que Está
realizando estamos viendo otros países
de América Latina como Ecuador Colombia
Bolivia y todos los países que hoy en
día dependen de las exportaciones tienen
algo muy grande y una gran incer el
problema aquí es que dejar algo bien en
claro la industria de hidrocarburos no
va a desaparecer en el año 2050 ni en el
2060 esto Esta estructura de
hidrocarburos por lo que estamos viendo
y lo que hemos calculado va a llegar más
allá del año 2100 y la transición de
carros eléctricos ya 100% puros no
híbridos yo creo que ya lo vamos a
alcanzar su totalidad a nivel mundial en
el año 2080 a 2100 entonces hoy los que
están en el sector de hidrocarburos creo
que no debemos de estar preocupando y lo
que sí hay que hacer son investigaciones
en donde puedas tener una mejor calidad
de crudo aprovechar las condiciones que
estás teniendo en una planta de
refinación en un centro de procesamiento
de gas O donde tú creas que sea
conveniente para que puedas mejorar
tanto la eficiencia energética como la
calidad
importante ese punto que usted señala
ramses los hidrocarburos no van a
desaparecer de la noche a la mañana eso
es importante decirlo pero esa esa
transición si puede haber alternativas a
esta a esta modelo de extracción para
para producir energía y poner en marcha
muchas economías alrededor del mundo
depende netamente de la extracción y
producción y exportación de petróleo
Gerardo su opinión sobre este proceso de
transición que tenemos que dar en
América Latina qué tan avanzados estamos
Qué países han dado pasos clave y van
liderando este proceso y bueno no sé si
vale la pena compararnos con algún país
europeo que esté en algún paso más o
menos igual al de nosotros como para
entender En qué nivel estamos o Europa
está muy adelantada
no no nos podemos comparar con ningún
país europeo pero la matriz energética
por lo menos de América del Sur es de la
más limpias que hay en el planeta gran
componente hidroelectricidad y un avance
muy fuerte de las energías renovables no
convencionales como eólica y solar por
lo tanto está en una buena situación
América del Sur para encarar la
transición energética Centroamérica
también lleva una buena delantera Costa
Rica es un país
limpio Uruguay es un país limpio en
América del Sur
y la historia nos ha mostrado haciendo
el Paralelo que mencionaba al principio
que estas crisis y este salto de los
precios del petróleo
son el origen de la sustitución de
combustibles de fuentes de energía y de
formas de consumo por lo tanto
América Latina está en una buena
posición para encarar este proceso y
este para disminuir su vulnerabilidad
energética Aunque ciertamente y en eso
Tiene mucha razón Ramsés nunca o por lo
menos en el mediano y largo plazo la
industria petrolera va a dejar de seguir
funcionando es la inercia se mantiene
pero las nuevas tecnologías ya comienzan
a desplegarse y las
desde lo del cambio climático los
eventos extremos que se están
produciendo sequías inundaciones
Huracanes etcétera obligan a
acelerar este proceso de transición aún
cuando se siga consumiendo pero en menor
medida combustible viendo Entonces el
panorama uno ve que América Latina va a
tener dificultades subirán los precios
la inflación va a haber una diferentes
aspectos afectados por por esta decisión
de la OPEP pero la región tiene formas
de abastecerse de petróleo garantizar
reservas y de mantener cierta
reservas de petróleo pero que hay por
ejemplo de Europa que está en una
coyuntura muy difícil para abastecerse
de petróleo son muy pocos los países que
en el continente europeo producen bueno
está Noruega está Escocia en el norte y
hay algunos vecinos que entonces en este
momento se deben de estar frotando las
manos Ramsés por ejemplo Argelia
azerbaiyán me atrevería en la lista
también turkmenistán que produce
muchísimo gas pero entonces qué le puede
esperar a Europa si ya estaban caras los
precios de la energía ahora que se puede
esperar
Bueno yo creo que en Europa hicieron una
estrategia muy buena considera el gas
natural como una energía reno este
renovable por así llamarlo de este
limpia la están considerando que no
produce de tantas emisiones de dióxido
de carbono si fueran El ejemplo del
Carbón y lo segundo es por ejemplo en el
Reino Unido ya liberaron la restricción
que tenían de la perforación en
formaciones de shell que es la misma
formación que Estados Unidos Fue produce
más de 8 millones de barriles diarios y
también tiene más de 90 millones de 90
mil millones de pies cúbicos de
producción diaria estamos viendo países
de Europa que están abriéndose sobre
todo la industria hidrocarburo se iban
eliminar el carbón en un momento dado
pero se están migrando al sector de
hidrocarburos sobre todo en ejercer
presión para poder recuperar pozos de
aguas profundas meterse en formaciones
de shell que en el Reino Unido y en
sobre todo en en la parte de Inglaterra
y en esas zonas de ahí se pueden
producir pozos Y esto es muy importante
porque Estados Unidos hacer un Aliado
del Reino Unido y ver que Estados Unidos
tiene tanta información Porque desde el
año 2010 han empezado a perforar este
tipo de formaciones ellos tienen más de
900.000 900 mil pesos produciendo hoy en
día los 12 millones de barriles diarios
y los más de 120 mil millones de pies
cúbicos creo que Estados Unidos se va a
convertir en un Aliado sobre todo para
Europa ante las restricciones que vienen
en diciembre al mandar una mayor
producción de crudo Por eso digo que
Estados Unidos va a incrementar su
producción hasta 13 millones de barriles
diarios y pienso yo que pudieran llegar
hasta 14 millones de de barriles diarios
y y van a mandar una mayor cantidad de
gas natural licuado porque estamos
viendo que las exportaciones de Estados
Unidos hacia la comunidad europea han
aumentado y hoy con la restricciones de
Rusia Esto va a ser un gran negocio y lo
hemos visto ahorita en las últimas
semanas que un flete de ida y vuelta de
una de una de un barco de gas natural
licuado está costando alrededor los 500
mil dólares en el día al día
sí son otras cifras que difíciles de
comprender lo que vale toda esta
industria y lo que significa para los
países poder abastecerse definitivamente
no es tan fácil como no pensaría llegar
a acceder a esas esas cantidades o
necesidades de gas y de petróleo que son
fundamentales para los países vuelvo con
rams para analizar la controversia ya
que usted habla de Estados Unidos el
presidente biden pidió hacer algunas
consultas con el congreso de Estados
Unidos sobre algunas herramientas y
autoridades adicionales o un marco legal
adicional precisamente para reducir ese
control que tiene la OPEP que controla
más o menos el 40% del mercado mundial
de petróleos temas corregirán si la
cifra no es exacta pero pero para
quitarle Tanto poder y Estados Unidos
como usted dice está en una posición
favorable en este momento podría pasar a
controlar un poco más en el mercado qué
piensa usted
si aumenta la producción hasta 14
millones de barriles diarios Sí porque
podría sustituir los dos millones de
barriles diarios que está haciendo el
recorte del OPEP en este momento Estados
Unidos lo hizo en un año yo creo que
podía hacerlo más lo más rápido posible
hay muchos pozos que todavía en Estados
Unidos no están terminados y esto podía
incrementar una mayor producción y hay
que dejar algo muy muy claro Estados
Unidos quiere tener una reactivación
económica y más o menos empleos directos
en el sector de hidrocarburos que se
tienen en Estados Unidos son de 2.5
millones de personas imagínense solo en
Texas hay empleos directos más de 220
mil personas de en forma directa en el
sector de hidrocarburos e imagínense si
pueden aumentar dos millones de barriles
diarios hemos de recordar que en Estados
Unidos más del 85% de la extracción de
hidrocarburos es en tierra imagínense
Cómo no podría generar una escala
económica en los lugares donde se hace
una mayor cantidad de hidrocarburos lo
vemos en la zona de permian que
anteriormente habían Salgado de 10.000
dólares y hoy están viendo salarios de
70.000 hasta 120 dólares en forma
anualizada es ahí donde Estados Unidos
Está tratando de apostar y hay que ver
también Estados Unidos si va a liberar
lo que los perdidos federales para poder
seguir explotando en ciertos lugares que
habían ciertas restricciones por parte
del presidente del aire hay muchas
estrategias muchas incertidumbre pero la
realidad es única los hidrocarburos en
el mundo se necesitan por las próximas
clases y hay que tenerlos en el mercado
y hay que seguir extrayendo del interior
de la tierra para poder suministrar en
los mercados Pero eso en un escenario de
un país como Estados Unidos donde tiene
una forma de producir tiene el talento
para el talento humano preparado para
poderlo producir extraer exportar pero
Gerardo que hay de los países en donde
no hay tanta capacidad Cuál es el peso
político que esto le va a costar a los
gobiernos de turno que van a tener que
hacer frente a los problemas económicos
a una ciudadanía inconforme exigiendo
medidas rápidas y drásticas para poder
solucionarla la situación va a haber
mucha presión sobre los gobiernos de
turno
y Empezando por Europa no es cierto
Europa Hoy está
viendo la ruptura del paradigma de la
Unión Europea
hace un tiempo atrás con la salida del
Reino Unido pero ahora con con mucha
resistencia de muchos países a seguir el
liderazgo de Alemania y buscando
oportunidades para que esta crisis no
los golpee este de una forma muy cruenta
este invierno en Europa va a ser muy
complicado en América Latina también el
impacto es importante la inflación el
acceso a la seguridad energética y el
acceso a combustibles
digamos
a buen precio va a ser complicado Y ya
en una situación económica
con altos índices de pobreza
esto Esta crisis
va a ser muy difícil de afrontar claro
con las herramientas que hoy tienen
nuestros países para para seguir
adelante no Claro claro Gerardo Ramsés
que hay de Rusia un país que está con
serias sanciones internacionales le está
vendiendo un poco más de su producción
de petróleo a India y a China pero ya
estamos hablando de una desaceleración
de China por primera vez en muchos años
china va a crecer por debajo del
crecimiento del continente eso es un
síntoma que preocupa mucho a los
economistas lo doy la palabra ramses
para que nos explique el panorama ruso
bueno panorama ruso es muy importante
sobre todo entender que Rusia está
reduciendo la producción en función de
las contracciones que están teniendo y
las restricciones pero Rusia hay que
darle en los próximos últimos en los
últimos meses ha dado descuentos entre
30 y 25 dólares por barril a China y la
India esto les ha ayudado a mantener un
volumen determinado de exportaciones
estos dos países aquí Lo importante hay
que dejarlo bien claro Rusia si tiene
entre 55 y 60 dólares el precio del
barril todavía sigue siendo una ganancia
para ellos por eso estamos viendo que
Rusia está esperando que el precio del
barril se mantenga los próximos meses
por arriba de los 95 dólares para poder
seguir ofreciendo los descuentos Entre
25 y 30 dólares y este todavía le sigue
beneficiando los ingresos que va a tener
Rusia aquí le pregunta no es que lo
utilice el dinero para la invasión hacia
Ucrania es la pregunta es desde el punto
de vista económico Rusia va a poder
mantenerse en la certidumbre económica
para el año 2023 destinado que no va a
tener una gran flujo un flujo de
efectivo ante las nuevas restricciones
que acaban de salir hoy de la Unión
Europea en donde muchas de estas hay
restricciones de personas de Europa que
no pueden estar dentro de empresas rusas
y su perspectiva Gerardo para el cierre
Bueno hoy Estaba viendo que Rusia le fue
mucho mejor en el frente económico que
en el militar con esta guerra nunca le
ingresó tantas Divisas y tanto dinero
por sus exportaciones de crudo y de gas
natural
un dato que me parece muy importante
para poder analizar el contexto
geopolítico que se viene es que no se
rompió la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo Plus que los países de la OPEP
de medio oriente y Rusia siguen
coordinando sus políticas petroleras
Esta es una señal muy fuerte para
occidente que hay que tener en cuenta y
hay que ver Cuáles son los elementos de
respuesta
aquí digamos
por un lado podemos ver que se va a ver
afectada Rusia por las sanciones
económicas pero por el otro hay un nuevo
diseño del orden geopolítico mundial que
hay que estar muy atento y ver cómo
continuar que es justamente lo que
estaba buscando el presidente Putin con
esta invasión a Ucrania era hacer un
rompimiento en el orden internacional
para forzar un escenario en donde ellos
tienen un papel un poco más destacado y
donde Estados Unidos no es el
protagonista de la historia vamos a ver
si eso les funciona por lo menos con la
venta de petróleo Tal parece que sí les
está funcionando según lo que nos dicen
ustedes Ramsés Gerardo les agradezco
mucho por haber explicado este análisis
haber hecho este análisis y habernos
explicado en palabras muy simples A qué
es lo que nos vamos a enfrentar en los
próximos meses en tema de hidrocarburos
y de combustibles Muchísimas gracias Es
todo por hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico les agradezco por la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Pedro Ruiz y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Muchas gracias por la sintonía
sigan con 4
[Música]